so What's this called open we let these
spiders bite our [__] or something
that's it
yeah that's it I'm [__] ruled
why don't we even talk about the sketch
yes I guess there's a spider that gives
you a boner that's what it was right
yeah can you bring this up
I'm very curious about this
got all the wrong [__] yeah
yeah exactly
that's the one he was hoping for yeah
yeah and then he was like ah what I come
out of my wrist instead no that's not
what I want you just get that little
spider he's like come on man come on buy
it come on man eat that thing come on
man Austrian Supermarket shut down due
to spider that can cause long painful
erections how many were in this
Supermarket that they had to shut it
down or was it just one big ass one
oh yeah that's a great question where
multiple people walking around with
giant boners I'm like constantly and the
managers were like something's going on
here yeah people are really horned up in
the store I think two employees got
caught smashing
it was a manager and uh
and a cashier they got caught smashing
and there's no this was the giant test
yeah Spicer to make me hard is that
Austrian I don't know what Austrian
really sounds like it's just Arnold
right yeah
[Laughter]
I had the big boner yeah yeah that's it
yeah do you know anyone second Viagra
and it just didn't go away uh uh I feel
like I've heard
someone tell me that story before but
yeah one of my boys took it it just
wasn't so did he go to the hospital no
no get it deflated nah he just literally
just sat around pin just sat around yeah
yeah
oh damn it
no no no come back
if we do this it's irreversible you can
never get this back yeah yeah if we pop
your boner
[__] air in there huh that's crazy
deflated balloon after
that sucks yeah I think he just like
jerked it a couple times and then just
sat around and yeah I believe that's
what happened yeah it would be
it would be kind of scary if you jerk it
and then nothing
and then it's still there and you're
like that'd be scary yeah that'd be
scary as [__] [__] yeah this usually
works yeah just smacking your dick come
on man yeah
it's slapping on the tables come on SLAP
it if it's like painfully hard that's
true yeah it's like flexing into you
your [__] is borderline like looking
back
[Laughter]
that's that's what Vault that's what
Harry Potter was or that's what
Voldemort was in Harry Potter a big
boner it's just a metaphor for a guy who
like you know it's like something
growing it starts by like something
growing on him yeah right just that the
beginning of his character it's like a
dick yeah
took Viagra and then it slowly took over
the host body and then the host body
became what the Viagra created
totally yeah yeah that was really funny
so I want to end with uh just Tatum the
dude that we reviewed we we got a cameo
from him remember the singer my favorite
artist right oh right so we got a cameo
from him I haven't seen it yet but I
wanted to watch it together to end our
episode okay let's get it Cody and Noel
just had him here in the flesh Phoenix
Arizona wishing y'all the best but you
guys are already killing it I've seen
the episode 302 yesterday I appreciate
being the artist mentioned you guys
listening you guys actually having the
most genuine reactions it wasn't thought
you guys weren't being egotistical it
was just literally listen to it you guys
felt something and I seen that and
that's what it's all about art I'm an
artist is deeper than the words it's
deeper than the looks and dying the hair
it's just kind of like
is something and you guys thank you for
joining the journey in the beginning
it's gonna be a fun long ride just
seeing pieces of the puzzle of a million
piece puzzle this is the beginning even
though this is 10 years and still the
beginning because it's who I am as an
artist all right as an artist okay the
Walkman by my boys TMG so I really hope
that y'all love my little rendition
send me the link if y'all put it in your
podcast I would love to watch it with
he's about to walk man
is that what he just said yeah wait what
love and peace again just Tatum Phoenix
Arizona peace out
[Music]
we ain't good yeah I'm a fat man faded
chewing girls like Pac-Man DMG on your
walk man you ain't messing with it you
you you can't take a walk man
take a walk hey take a walk you don't
wanna push my buttons take a walk take a
walk take a walk hey hey take a walk
yeah you don't wanna push my buttons
take a walk please man take a walk just
Adam TNG in the building 302 that's the
episode
I need a break
before I hear me
anything related to me I need an actual
break yeah
let's low like the blunt smoke feeling
rnp holding Blue no
TMG yeah
I just he didn't like the second half of
yours that's okay laughs that's okay it
was like uh I'm good yeah
ended it there
you went a little bit through your verse
and I was like Ah that's uh that's where
the song ends
holy [__] that was better than I could
have ever imagined that was an
experience
just had him just Dad him I'm getting
I'm getting
tatted after this
I'm going I have a tattoo appointment
what are you getting the Iron Man tattoo
what are you gonna put it I don't know
yet
but I'm gonna be just kneecap to added
kneecap now it's gonna hurt like a [__]
uh the your Iron Man I think I thought I
was I think I'm gonna get it on my dick
sorry we don't have enough width for the
oh right
bro kneecap is hard man
it would hurt like hell but how [__]
tough would that be so your armor yeah
me too
that would actually be pretty sick like
kneecap yeah yeah like would you get on
the thigh [__]
yeah we'll see we'll see I'm gonna make
a game time decision on where it's gonna
go
yeah
right here
like the Majin Buu yeah which is yeah
Iron Man
anyways
thank you just had him for the Cameo
thanks for what a insane cover a walk
man I didn't think Walkman could get
any worse yeah I don't think it could be
more cringe
and he did it
uh just tell him he he made me feel like
we shouldn't have wrote that
[Laughter]
you made me feel
like oh we should delete that
yeah we might take it down actually yeah
now
we might take it down
that'd be tough as [__] just delete our
whole artist page
yeah it never happened yeah yeah
and then the only version is that
version I just had him yeah
it's his song now oh [__] we should give
him the song we just swap it yeah all
those streams yeah swap the file you got
it man yeah you can have it
that's you
that was a that was amazing though that
was [__] yo Luke do you want to keep
your job don't ever show me the lyrics
to that song ever again
I am a fat man though
um
[Music]
I'm a fat man